[Musique]
nous sommes dans un pays aujourd'hui où
on commence à travailler de plus en plus
tard où on part à la retraite de plus en
plus tôt où l'on vit de plus en plus
vieux et où l'on travaillerait de moins
en moins durant sa vie active
moi je me demande comment nous allons
laisser la france pour les générations
futures
je pense qu'on a baissant les charges on
recréera des emplois
nous pourrons à nouveau recruter du
personnel
nous avons un certain nombre d'années de
travail derrière nous et notre principal
souci est la jeunesse qui monte et qui
va faire la france de demain j'attends
de jacques chirac si l'aide ces jeunes
qui sont perdus dans la société à se
remettre au plaza à trouver leur voie
être épanoui socialement qu'il trouve un
travail et je pense que jacques chirac
est la personne qui peut les aider dans
ces problèmes je veux libérer nos
énergies pour que la france soit tourné
vers l'avenir vers l'emploi vers la
création de richesses et donc un
meilleur partage le chômage et la crème
du chômage sont au coeur des
préoccupations de nos compatriotes
il frappe d'abord les travailleurs aux
revenus moyens et modestes
la priorité c'est de baisser les charges
non pas pour des raisons
idéologique des parce que c'est le seul
moyen est en tous les cas le moyen le
plus efficace de relancer l'activité et
l'emploi
c'est ainsi que près de 500 mille
emplois selon l'insee ont été créées par
les mesures prises en 93 et en 95 je
m'engage à ce que votre travail et vos
efforts soient mieux récompensée par une
baisse de la fiscalité personnelle qui
est trop souvent confiscatoire
aujourd'hui l'impôt sont revenus sera
réduit de 5% dès 2002 et d'un tiers en
cinq ans l'origine de la taxe
d'habitation sera remis à plat pour
lutter contre le chômage de longue durée
qui atteint des travailleurs dans leur
dignité et qui peut mener à l'exclusion
je propose de redéfinir nos politiques
d'insertion avec deux engagements forts
signé un contrat d'insertion avec
l'ensemble des allocataires du rmi et
accompagner toute reprise d'activité
d'une augmentation significative du
pouvoir d'achat par le revenu minimum
d'activité
il est en effet inacceptable en france
que 25 % des allocataires du revenu
minimum d'insertion voient leurs revenus
diminuer quand ils retrouvent un emploi
au psg
cela relève d'une culture qui consiste à
ôter toute valeur au travail et à
l'effort voudrait qu'une attention toute
particulière soin des âmes désormais
apporter aux travailleurs des plus
petites entreprises qui n'ont ni les
mêmes droits ni la même stabilité
d'emploi il souvent les mêmes salaires
et des mêmes horaires que dans la
plupart des grandes entreprises essaient
d'avoir en pensant à eux que j'ai
proposées pour tous les salariés
un système d'assurance emploi qui
étendra leurs droits à formation à
reconversion à reclassement désormais
chaque français devrait pouvoir
bénéficier d'un compte personnel de
formation nos entreprises vous savez
sont compétitives elles gina et elle
exporte mais il ya beaucoup à faire pour
rendre la france vraiment attractif
notre fiscalité reste trop lourde et
c'est pourquoi j'ai proposé de ramener
le taux de l'impôt sur les sociétés à la
moyenne européenne
il faut rendre la création d'entreprise
aussi simple que les par exemple la
création d'une association c'est ainsi
que nous ouvrirons les portes les portes
de l'audace créatrice des portes que
l'on a besoin d'ouvrir et notamment aux
jeunes qui sont pleins d'idées plein de
talent métro
ce sens n'est pas venu
à
oui
[Musique]